curtis frank is a 28 year old gold
broker from fountain hills arizona he
was born in wisconsin and has five
brothers and sisters
he was asked over 50 questions by a
polygraph examiner 21 have been chosen
for tonight tonight you brought family
and friends here as well let's meet them
hi i'm marie curtis's mom that haircut
is how you know this is an old show yeah
you don't see that haircut unless you
watch i was like cheers
hi i'm aurora
i'm cody curtis's little brother i'm
john curtis's friend
question six for ten thousand dollars
do you tell your friends intimate
details about the women you date
[Applause]
[Music]
how do you feel to know that i know that
he's told me that he never he doesn't do
that really
[Applause]
it gave it away
excuse me look at his face right now he
went
i mean he told her he told her what she
needed to hear yeah yeah
and he's looking at him like oh you're
not even gonna hide your face
[Music]
aurora
how do you feel to know that i know that
he's told me that he never he doesn't do
that really yeah
[Music]
oh man you ain't double wing
do you tell your friends
intimate details about the women you
date yes or no
yes
you do i do
[Music]
cody john have you heard any of these
details before
[Laughter]
don't answer that one we already know
moving on to the next answer he's just
like i remember what the told me
looked like
i think i know the answer already yeah
you've heard what's telling the truth
what what what what guy doesn't right
um
[Music]
i mean there's definitely people who do
oh yeah but that's not my thing that's a
no problem no sir oh that's a no keep it
private it's how you keep keep problems
away
let's find out if that answer is true or
false
that answer is
why she already crying at the first
question that's the first one booboo you
you are not gonna last you are not gonna
like you
today's video is sponsored by wait
all right you already know
okay we're ready today's video is
sponsored by blue chew say it with us
now blue chips it's time for you to gain
more confidence and longer lasting
experiences in the bedroom with
bluetooth tablets okay you deserve
better she deserves harder listen
bluechu is a unique online service that
offers you the same active ingredients
as a viagra in cialis but in a true form
and at a fraction of the cost and one of
the best parts is that you know
bluetooth it's an online service so you
don't need to go to the doctor and have
an awkward conversation with that person
all you gotta do is go to bluetooth.com
you just need to consult with one of
their medical licensed professionals and
once you're approved we just ship it to
your door and we got a special deal just
for you guys you can try bluetooth for
free when you use promo code abba all
right and all you gotta do is pay for
the five dollar shipping that's
bluechew.com using promo code abba and
get your first month free so big shout
out to bluetooth for sponsoring this
video question 11
have you ever told someone you'd been
tested for a sexually transmitted
disease when in fact you hadn't
there's a bunch of people at home being
like
[Laughter]
yeah he's in the cringe zone how are we
going to survive this oh yeah
these questions are ruthless he's at 11.
yes
that answer is
[Music]
true congratulations you've just won 25
but i need to do something for this
because it's killing my face her face
nice
like when you try not to cry she's
trying not to go she's trying so hard
she's trying so hard it's not working
have you ever stolen money from the
family business
[Applause]
[Music]
if you don't want to know you can hit
the button do you want him hit the
button
[Music]
not answering the question is answering
the question
even if it's them because you know you
know you know we all know because you
know
okay do you secretly want to get back
together with your girlfriend aurora
aurora is her
yeah
thanks girl we're sitting there
that's his ex-girlfriend that's his
ex-girlfriend
i think she's doing it after all this
this brings her if i can smile oh my god
girl she's too innocent
jesus christ all that wiped oh
oh
wow girl what do you think his answer
will be aurora um
i don't know
uh my answer is yes
[Applause]
now you're clapping and you're good
she's she's a wonderful girl i'd love to
love to be with her yeah i love her
aurora
who broke up with whom this this time
um it was mutual we both
obviously not too mutual
any chance that uh this relationship
will rekindle
um you never question 15
for 100 000
while you were dating your former
girlfriend aurora did you ever cheat on
her
the order of these questions is perfect
no we know we'll never know oh we'll
know
aurora any thoughts on this
um
i don't think he ever did
well there's no button to save you now
you have to answer this truthfully or
lose your 25 000.
yes
[Applause]
national tv huh i need to walk out
that answer is
true
[Music]
this is not good
our night of parting has just gone down
the tubes
are not a partying has just gone down
the tubes this was trying to get
lit
when yo where's that like l.a uh where
did it be vegas when vegas went to l.a
we were in new york whatever we're gonna
get lit after oh we're not gonna
get none of that order before that
perfect
oh man this show was so good at
destroying people
that's not the answer you wanted to hear
hon aurora no
i'm sorry to see you uh
you know tearing up it's okay we have a
word for this it's called mesquine
and miss keane's like
oh know what someone's like hurting like
a little puppy like yeah that's what she
is right now she's biscuit i feel bad
don't you feel bad for her no no no some
people are just innocent like they don't
know anybody they don't feel bad for
them no no it's like that's life there's
innocent people we need them oh no
for this question
um
but it's out there now
and uh here good thank you
aurora is this something we can come
back
you know what she looks like you know
those kids would get beat when they get
told they can't cry
you know what i'm talking about
they're just sitting there with their
face
are you going to cry
no no
back from
[Music]
three more truthful answers you double
that money to 200 000
that's a lot of money you know the
questions you were asked maybe the ones
you were most worried about
like that last one are out and done the
damage is done so maybe it's smart to
continue uh maybe it isn't only you can
answer that question what do you want to
do
[Applause]
[Music]
that's it he came on he embarrassed her
got his money and then left
200 000 is pretty good good night party
let's go
hookers overall no all right
that's exactly it that's exactly it
moral of the story
if your ex invites you on a dating show
don't go she suffered all the emotional
backlash for nothing and she's not
getting a dime with that money and mama
mama's not too proud either but whatever
and she got made a fool of our national
television
don't care about aurora
she's color kind but the family business
we don't wreck that
but that's a ruthless episode i didn't
enjoy what did you guys think
feel bad did you feel bad for her for
him i don't know let's hear your
thoughts leave it in the comments below
[Music]